[Music]
now tonight the extreme radical 2020
socialist Democrats are even getting too
radical for their partners their best
friends and the hate Trump media mob
some of them including Don Lemon and
thrill up my leg Chris Matthews the
beginning to sound the alarm
maybe you shouldn't tell people how you
really feel just hide it like you used
to take a look what do you mean by that
because I don't see how he wins again
with the numbers that he has right now I
don't have seen what the Democrats you
can't beat somebody with nobody it's
hard to identify a leading can--it that
is resisting the group moved to the left
bottom line going into the Democratic
primaries is not the same as going to
the country
joining us now media reporter with the
hill also wor my fellow wor our host
radio host Jill Concha Ward winning
journalist Lara Logan Larry we've lived
through this before
it's called Barack Obama mania the only
difference now is they're even pushing
harder to the left I don't think you can
stop that deal well you know you Sean
I'm not a politician right and I'm not a
political reporter so I don't know
whether you can stop but or not my
concern as a journalist is looking is
trying to figure out what the facts are
and and trying to figure out what people
are actually representing what they
actually are trying to do in the
election and also and as journalists it
seems to me you know our job is to is to
do that right that's how jutti but what
I really want to know is Don Lemon Chris
Cuomo are they opinion hosts are these
opinion shows or these news programs
because that's an important distinction
and what people tell me American people
everywhere I go in this country that's
what they want to know when they turn on
the news they want the facts when they
turn on an opinion show like yours they
want your opinion right so where do
these people stand and stand I am a
radio and TV talk show host we do I have
hundreds of hours I can produce a street
reporting god forbid a shooting a war or
natural disaster straight reporting some
that we investigated Obama nobody else
would would investigate the deep state
nobody else would we do investigative
work the
they're too lazy and too partisan to do
we also do opinion and sometimes sports
and sometimes cultural issues we're like
the whole newspaper that's my role in
the press is that a fair description or
unfair joke on ship I think people tune
in primarily for your opinions but you
cover the other stuff you have to you're
in cable news and 24/7 produce hundreds
of hours of Smee straight story
reporting just the facts that's fine but
I think most of the time people want to
know your perspective on a certain news
particular do you really want my opinion
or something that's news breaking this
is owned all Rockets being fired into
Israel that's I could answer Lara
Logan's question and that is that on the
CNN website Cuomo and lemon are listed
as anchors and clearly they're giving
opinions you just showed one but as far
as the left talking about this worry
that the party is going too far left
Politico had a good story last month
that talked about and this wasn't based
on somebody's opinion but economic
models with strong track records and
picking presidential winners and losers
and they cite strong US economy rising
wages low gas prices and historical
advantage held by a presidential
incumbent and they say that if you look
at all those factors President Trump
will win in a landslide I don't think
we're in a landslide culture anymore I
think it's hard we're too polarized but
based on that alone and the fact that
Democrats are going with Medicare for
all green New Deal eliminate the
electoral college more regulation
expanding that it's after birth abortion
after right all those things expanding
the Supreme Court all those ideas will
be rejected by the one part of the base
that matters most and that's
independence Laura I there is a very
different standard you were on 60
minutes this is that you know I don't
see that anymore I don't even see 60
minutes is fair because they you know
tape you for 10 hours and chop it down
to 15 minutes that's called edited fake
news and well that happens shown to
everybody I have to say and and Joe you
know the thing is that anchor doesn't
answer my question because as an
organization where to CNN stand have you
taken a political position or have you
not
you know what where did the
problem with what has been happening in
the media as far as I'm concerned is
that we claim the middle ground not even
to be objective and we're not